I'm Trevor Phillips this is Common
Ground where each week we look for
agreement on a hot button issue dividing
the nation
tonight if the union leaders to continue
to be unreasonable then it is my duty to
take action to protect the lives and
livelihoods of the British public
sectors every day until Christmas as
Britain braces for a winter of chaos and
disruptions it doesn't to me see markets
in the interest of patients and I think
if anything is going to put fear amongst
the general public which is unnecessary
and again it goes against the core
values of being a nurse so I have
colleagues that are using food banks and
I have had colleagues you know tell
their children that they don't think
that Christmas is going to be a
particularly great Christmas film this
year I actually feel in a way fortunate
that I don't have children I have to say
that too and I want the government to
explain why they're not prepared to sit
down and even talk even though they know
that patients will experience real
disruption as a result of strike action
withdrawing your labor at Christmas time
is hardly news when a bunch of shepherds
walked off the job two thousand years
ago following Yonder star hardly anyone
blinked an eye or gave tuppence for the
fate of their flocks not so today
with rail workers nurses teachers and
more about to strike the economy's
idling and the sick uncared for critics
complain that Society shouldn't be held
to Ransom some categories of worker they
say should be forbidden from striking
unions and others are appalled forcing
people into the fields and factories
went out with the ark they say the
laborer should be worthy of his or her
higher and the government needs to stop
channeling Ebenezer Scrooge and give the
nurses Railway workers and others a rise
in line with inflation whatever it takes
our choice should the right to strike be
removed from some public functions or is
the freedom to walk away from work
sacrosanct
in the next 30 minutes we go in search
of common ground
[Music]
with me tonight Stephen Dorrell former
Health secretary who was also chair of
the NHS Confederation
Lord David Howell former transport
secretary who served in a variety of
roles for governments of Ted Heath
Margaret Thatcher and David Cameron and
Mary busted joint General Secretary of
the National Education Union
um let's start on this Common Ground we
know that already there are some groups
of workers soldiers uh some in the
life-saving business who are essentially
prohibited by law from withdrawing their
labor but the question that we're trying
to address today is should that Circle
be widened and if so in what way uh
they tell you um
worked for Heath who was essentially
defeated by unions he worked for
Thatcher who most people would say
defeated certainly the miners and David
Cameron who I don't think ever really
had to face what we're facing today
um do we need to extend the prohibitions
on striking I think Society is getting
so complex and the the word was
life-saving and so we must look at
life's threatening activities they are
widening and becoming more complex even
things like blocking blocking trains or
blocking motorways blocking transport
could be life-threatening so we do have
to think all the time about waiting I'm
sorry it's come to this present crisis
which I think I want to look at the
facts behind it but um yes we do only be
should be on our guard to think of ways
of whitening it yep all right well we'll
talk about exactly how Mary bastard do
you see the case irrespective of the
specifics of one in the one industrial
relations dispute or another do you
think that there is a case as David
Houser said for in thinking about where
the public is endangered prohibiting the
withdrawal of Labor
well
unions which are engaged in
um uh in work which involves life life
um you know the the loss of life or the
maintenance of life for example in
health
if they take strike action they will
make sure that Critical Care is
maintained and the RCN and Unison and
others which are engaged in the health
dispute have made that really clear so
there will be no threat to loss of life
from the action of health workers taking
action on Thursday
and
um we already have and I'm sure we'll
come into this some of the most
restrictive strike laws in the world so
so restrictive in fact that there's a
case before the international labor
organization that the restrictions on
taking industrial action in the UK are
unlawful according to International
labor law so any extension would be
completely unjustified all right Stephen
Doral do uh where do where do you stand
on this I'm not in favor of extending
the Banning of strike action uh
fundamentally I think for a simple
reason of principle that if the employer
employee relationship deteriorates to a
strike the only way you will rebuild it
is by rebuilding the relationship
between them and introducing the law
Banning strike action makes that more
difficult rather than easier success in
the current health service and indeed in
the rail dispute and other dispute leads
relies upon both employer and employee
finding common ground and I think that's
made more difficult not easier by a
threat of strike action by a threat of
banning strikes all right well let's
take that up because um let's talk about
the the nature strikes then they aren't
always just an accidental thing that
happens are they we live in a market
society and one element of the market is
labor and there is nothing in principle
wrong against uh with labor exercising
the raw power that it has in the same
way as employers exercise their power so
it isn't just a question of when things
break down uh the
unions may decide that actually this
moment is a moment to their advantage
isn't they oh might they not it's
certainly true in any voluntary
relationship that there will be moments
when people are more powerful and
moments when people are less powerful
and I certainly not my view that the law
has no role in an employer employee
relationship that's the hope that there
is a whole Corpus of law that determines
what you can and can't put into an
employment contract but at its heart an
employment contract is an employer is a
is an agreement between an employer and
an employee and if that's going to be a
successful relationship Banning strike
action I think doesn't doesn't help the
situation all right
and what lies behind the sort of
situation we're in now that you I think
already interested in and why it should
come to a stage where so many people
want to go on strike and I think we have
to look at three things here the the
context which is actually unique in
history we've we've been through on our
present in conditions of the like of
which we haven't known since the 1940s
secondly we in we're in the midst of a
dangerously High inflation rate I think
that's going to come down but there are
a lot of fears around about that and
thirdly we've really let us sort of uh
digital capitalism of a really
unpleasant kind develop which we should
have headed off years ago with more
Universal social capitalism what do you
mean by that digital I mean I mean I
mean the fat cats I read in the papers
the other day some guys awarding himself
500 million pounds as an income as
income and for one year this is mad the
the the that side of the systems created
a concentration of ownership and capital
on a scale not even known in the 18th
century in the height of dukes and
Grandes and so on this is this is crazy
so no wonder it's opened the way for a
lot of politicking to come into strikes
we heard um Anderson this morning to um
uh Mr Lynch really talking
um Klaus Warfare he wanted he wanted all
the Fat Cats the rich to get poorer so
the poor could get richer we all know
that doesn't work and that's a very very
skilled indeed so the context is wrong
the message coming over from the
government I'm not very thrilled with at
all I don't think they've explained to
people that you can't just go around
demanding 19 or 20 so it's it's there's
a lot of the story behind this that I'd
love to talk more about Mary boss said
uh whatever one might say about Mick
Lynch and a great deal is said about
mclins there's no question that he is an
effective uh representative of his
sector
here's here's the question though I
think we all we're all agreeing
life-saving all of that that's got to be
protected
what happens when a group of workers
for perfectly good reasons from their
point of view are able to do something
that essentially uh affects the economy
of the country as a whole in their own
interest
is there a case for saying that
government
ought to be able to prevent that
happening
yeah
well governments should if they're
governing effectively
prevent the
um prevent the the feeling building up
amongst those workers that they have to
State strike action let's remember that
when workers take strike action they
lose pay
let's remember that we have very very
restrictive
um laws governing industrial action so
if you're in a public service which is
meant to be which is a critical Public
Service like like education we have a
ballot on at the moment we have to get
half the membership to vote and 40 of
the whole membership to vote Yes so if
we do so what that means is if we
achieve a 50 threshold of members voting
80 of those have to vote Yes in order
for the ballot to be legal we have to
write to every employer both when we're
going to set out the nature of the
dispute and before we take action we
have there's a
um a time limit on the time you can take
action so so unions don't take action
easily or quickly members lose money
um so you know what it but if a
government
refuses to fund Public Services
and neglects public services over a
12-year period until they're on their
knees what other action can workers take
to draw attention to that fact
of the strike action forgive me
interrupting I understand the case
that's being made for a strike at
industrial action of one kind or another
the question I was really asking I want
to come to Steve doralins in a second is
do you see that there may be a case for
somebody to say whatever just however
Justified the actions your members may
take that there's uh they're an opposing
point of view that says well
there's a problem for the teachers we
understand that but the cost to the
country of their action is intolerable
is that an unreasonable thing to say
well it's it's well it's unreasonable in
the context of uh the what is this the
the the the the underpayment the down
payment of of public sector workers so
the biggest threat to the public sector
is not through strikes it's through uh
public sector workers in nursing and in
teaching and in as prison officers and
as social workers walking away from
public service which means that public
services are on their knees how are my
members going to actually in the end
when they haven't been listened to for
12 years how are they going to
demonstrate their Worth to the public
about the valuable job they do other
than in the end as a last resort okay
there are already some categories as
workers that that can't withdraw their
labor the government's already made that
decision the answer to your question
Trevor is that the the call for Banning
strike action is a kind of Cry of
political frustration from those who
aren't prepared to sit down and address
the the the issues that lie at the heart
of the dispute it's an old cry it's
something's going wrong we should pass a
law against it well most problems as
David quite rightly says actually in a
modern society we live in a very complex
world so if we were to take your
principle for example when there were
those petrol drivers strike you remember
15 years ago we're talking about a few
hundred people there that demonstrated
their capacity to inflict significant
damage on the economy over a very short
period and what would you have done
enough should we ban them if and if we
ban petrol drivers what about people who
drive food to Sainsbury's that's pretty
important to maintaining life and health
so every we live in a very
interconnected world and it is it is
absolutely true that if individual
groups uh if if we lose the consent that
underlies those relationships then
things break down but we the the the
defaults are saying oh we should pass a
law against it is a substitute for
thinking about the problem seriously no
come on Stephen no one's proposing to
bet to pass a law Banning strikes that's
that's absurd that's Way Beyond that's
the question Trevor asked no no I said
we're not talking widen the prohibitions
why why didn't the prohibitions because
the nature of emergencies change and the
nature of the way in which life can be
threatened has got much more complicated
so all I said was and I think people
generally agree that this needs to be
revealed there is a bit of emotion now
in addition because I think in some of
the things that are being said and the
fact that it's all up against Christmas
and the fact that we've had two
miserable years of difficulty of
privation everyone was hoping in easier
Christmas this has just gone over the
age of reasonableness and I think in a
very reason about public in Britain they
just feel is pushing it a shade too far
so that's that's why that's why the
government has been brought to this
point but you've got to you've got to
remember they've got to remember and
then I want to put something just just
remember this all started with the worst
financial crash in history in 2008 and
the labor government going out of office
saying leaving a sad little note there
is no more money
after that we had covered and obviously
Ukraine emergency inflation you couldn't
expect this to be a generous handout
time because what you're making is the
arguments that I agree with quite a lot
of the points you make actually that
these are the arguments that need to be
made but where are ministers why aren't
ministers making these arguments why
haven't they been making them for weeks
and weeks and weeks in the television
Studio okay and and just if I may make a
rather simple Point are we really going
to say this is particularly serious
because we're running there's a run-up
to Christmas so we have a ban on strikes
in the week before Christmas oh
I know you're not uh you know you're not
a massive fan of capitalism but um your
view your view which says essentially
that you know workers uh may experience
privations of one kind or another and
this is the thing they have to do
um are you giving over our society to uh
Market forces and capitalism red in
tooth and Claw where actually
employers do what they want a labor does
what it wants and whoever wins at the
end of the day gets their way
well
would
no we're not doing that I mean
if you're not going to regulate it what
you're basically saying is whoever can
make the public uh bow to their will
wins
but but there are a little but there are
but you're not asking that within the
context we're working within but there
are very very strict laws in
um over industrial action and the union
only takes industrial action as a last
resort it's not it's not a nice time for
a general secretary leading a national
dispute it is full of risk it's full of
extremely hard work and whether you're
going to make the thresholds I mean
unions only take industrial action when
they've run out of Road and when the
employer or the government in our case
won't negotiate they are a they are a
sign of desperation they're a sign that
any attempt to get the employer or the
government to be reasonable has not
worked they're often a sign that the
employer or the government thinks that
that you know you're making it up as a
union Baron I mean the Daily Mail calls
me a union Baron frequently and um that
you know you're making a you're not
going to get over 50 of your members
voting and 80 of them voting yes unless
is a massive problem all right
um let's see if we can actually crawl
towards some common ground here let me
try something with you David Hull
um let's not tackle the rmt Mr Lynch is
is quite a fearsome beast and I don't
want to get into an argument I've
already had an argument with him
scored which was a score draw I think
but
let's deal with the if you like the
scope of any potential prohibitions
what about saying that only workers who
are effectively employed by government
might be subject to some kinds of uh
further prohibitions I'm talking about
those in Health Service possibly of
course those in education though yeah
that's a complicated question that again
is too simple for this complicated World
we've um you can love or hate
privatization and so on but all around
the world most enormous area utilities
and utilities which are related to
life-threatening or utilities related to
the entire business of communication in
a modern society and Technology are in
private hands and therefore any
prohibition about life with a
life-threatening concern is going to
have to cover more than just public
sector workers that's a dilemma that
we've got to work out in the future but
it's it's nevertheless it doesn't quite
match or a rather happy idea that just
it's just government workers who should
be told not to strike it's okay it's
just the Army and so on we've got to go
it's much more complicated okay failing
on failure number one but Stephen Doral
let me try something with you then
um minimum service levels I mean in lots
of uh parts of the economy you
particularly in the private sector
you're required to deliver a certain
products or services at a minimum level
of or you don't get paid um
would that be an idea that's worth
introducing particularly in relation as
I say where government is effectively
the employer
I'm not quite certain how that would
work in in a contractual situation but
one of the simple things distinctions we
have to draw here is between uh the
criminal law Banning something making it
contrary to the criminal law presumably
nobody's in favor of that and writing
contract terms and I I'm not quite
certain how you write a set of contract
terms uh that fulfilled the principle
you described can I just make the also
the other point uh you're suggesting
that this would apply to public sector
workers and and not private sector
workers there's a rather simple problem
with that which is that although people
look at the health service for example
and say that's tax funded therefore it's
public sector actually uh getting on for
a majority of the people who deliver
tax-funded services in the Health
Service work in the private sector the
GPS our private sector service providers
to the Health Service that was an Aaron
bevin's deal with BMA so on that
definition people working in Primary
Care could strike people working in the
hospitals couldn't okay
just to reinforce Stevens points of
course even the railways when we are
here now are tax-funded they're funded
as well as being in the private sector
so the whole of this language of what's
in the private sector and what isn't
actually the whole Ovation Asian Society
is moving beyond this ideological
Division and way of thinking we're in
the we're in the wrong Trot we're in the
wrong Valley intellectually in thinking
about left and right and state sector
and their state sector the modern world
is digitalized and people are empowered
and they want services and that takes
the argument a whole stage further
I well I know you spend quite a lot of
time in Japan and Southeast Asia and so
on
um would you favor something like the
situation in Singapore where government
actually has pretty strong powers
over what people when people can and
can't withdraw their layer later no it's
too strong for me I'm afraid oh
Singapore's too strong
you're all you're all basically
resisting the idea that this is
practical but maryborough said let me
ask you one other way in which this
might you might approach this coming
back to this point about minimum service
levels
um teachers will or may withdraw their
labor and there will be all sorts of
noise and arguments about that
going back to Stephen doral's point
about the difference between criminal
and civil action
um what would be wrong with uh schools
having Essentia contract with parents
that say they must deliver a certain
number of days teaching or whatever it
is how have you said it and that in
circumstances where that was not to
deliverable because of industrial
actions a parent would have a case
against school and or your union
well what's wrong with that is it mixes
up
um you know two very separate issues it
mixes up
um the idea of a the guarantee of a
service with the um with the fundamental
right to withdraw your labor and
when it comes to a profession like
teaching where teachers work more unpaid
over time than any other profession
um and you know when they transform
their practice during covid to offer
lessons remotely to Children young
people these are not people who withdraw
their labor easily that the fact that
they are we went through a preliminary
ballot and we got you know we smashed
the ballot thresholds the these teachers
and doctors and nurses and civil
servants uh driving instructors they're
not people who withdraw their labor
easily and the problem with minimum
service levels particularly with this
government is that they would be
um they would be put forward in a way
which wasn't minimum at all and which is
basically just yet another
um another wedge against the right to
withdraw your labor all right well look
um for the best part of this program
you've all resisted any attempts I I've
made to offer for a Peaceable
Progressive modern solution to the
gasoline I just agree with you
had if it seemed earlier back in the
cabinet now let's leave aside just give
them the money because that ain't gonna
happen what would you be saying
would I be reminding myself of is the
old Tony Blair dictum that I use very
often which is the democracy's
government by explanation
uh a minister holds office on behalf of
the public and needs to accept the
obligation to explain to the public what
the difficult choices that all ministers
in all governments what those choices
are and it's only by engaging in that
discussion that the general level at the
at the political level and at the level
of dealing with your own imp the
employees of your own Department
that's the that's the way in which you
build the trust that delivers not just
people going to work but people
delivering the high quality service that
motivates them which is the reason they
joined in the first place at Mary
bastard um let me indulge in a thought
experiment here
let's suppose for one moment you were
advising uh the Secretary of State for
Education about what to say to uh
National Education union leaders when
they come in
what would she say that would make you
you National Education Union and say oh
you know what
actually we should call off this this
strike
other than we'll give you every penny
you want
well look
um we we um put in the demand we're very
willing to negotiate we're ready to
negotiate so the first thing the
Secretary of State should do as we've
asked her to do repeatedly is to get
round the table and
um to first of all listen to the case
that we're putting forward listen to
that carefully secondly to accept that
it's not wage Rises at the moment which
are driving inflation it's um you know
the wage rises in the public sector are
falling about four percent bind to the
private sector and are nowhere near
matching the levels of inflation which
has been driven by uh the war and by the
price of energy so to say
um right okay then let's start
negotiating around that and let them to
enter into proper negotiations that's
what we've asked for you know the
government hasn't it's not only not it's
not only not explained it's not
negotiated okay Mary
um David Howell you're not going to get
anywhere with this are you yes I am
Mary's talking sense for another era
what I'm what I've been saying all along
this is where I agree with Stephen it's
explanation and the explanation frankly
if you want some agreement now I think
the present government admittedly after
certain difficulties print mildly to
decide who's going to lead it they've
got a prime minister and they've made a
pig's ear so far of explaining to the
public and to the unions about the level
of inflation next year which is going to
be much lower than people think all this
Goldman Sachs 18 is rubbish and about
the fact that we are in an immensely
dangerous okay virtually existential
situation all right we're being
threatened with nuclear weapons by
America Maniac in Moscow we're going
full shortages all right so everything
uh summer all right leaves are going to
be cut I mean here we are on this major
all right it isn't the time for this
sort of language it is all right
um
to to sum up and bring you all together
in one happy family uh as usual I have
failed completely there won't be that
much common ground on this except that
um
number one there's not much possibility
in practicality of extending uh
prohibitions on withdrawal of labor but
we have two former conservative cabinet
ministers who I think that they're too
polite to put it this way think that
this government is making a bit of a
pig's ear of just the process of dealing
with the unions right now and they need
to Buck up but maybe they can get some
lessons thank you very much all three of
you
stay with us we'll have all of today's
news coming up after the break
foreign
[Music]